Many of my friends sing the wonders of diversity.
I tried to tell them diversity isn't a moral good,
but I end up looking like some terrible racist.
Why isn't diversity moral good?
While diversity is our moral good,
but you can't,
diversity by race doesn't produce diversity.
That's,
that's called racism.
That idea or diversity of gender doesn't produce diversity unless that's how you
define diversity.
Look,
let's say that you get diversity partly as a consequence of personality,
which is a good way of looking at it.
There is more diversity within groups of people then between,
so like men and women differ to some degree in their personalities,
but there's far more difference between men within the male group and women
within the male group.
Then there is between the average or typical male and female.
So it's a stupid wait.
Let's assume that what you want,
the organization's pursuing your complex goal and you want a variety of skills
that would be suited to that goal.
Then you want there to be enough diversity of ability within the group so that
the goal can be achieved in a efficient and,
and uh,
and inexpensive manner.
Right?
Because what do you want
on efficient and expensive?
Obviously not.
So there's a presumption that you get diversity by using identity politics
categories,
but there's absolutely no evidence for that whatsoever.
So that's why diversity defined by race or ethnicity or gender is not only not a
moral good,
it's actually a moral evil because it dispenses with the whole idea of the
individual dispenses.
With the idea of competence.
It just replaces it with the assumption that if you randomly select from the
population,
because that's how you would get real equity,
you randomly select from the population that that gives you the best qualified
group of people.
Well that's just,
that's,
you wouldn't do that to select the plumber.
It's,
it's the stupidest possible way of selecting for anything randomly,
you know,
there's no difference between selecting randomly and selecting accidentally.
So it's moral diversity defined properly is a moral good diversity based on
identity,
politics categories is a positive evil,
you know,
true to our,
our prime ministers.
Great example of that.
So back,
I think it was in 2015 he announced that half of his cabinet was going to be
women because it was 2015 or something like muddle headed virtue signaling,
signaling excuse for not thinking.
I think only 20% or 25% of the elected mps were female.
So the proper balance on average would it be 25% female,
75% male.
What he should've done was figured out who,
what qualities would make for a competent cabinet minister because it's actually
quite important to have competent cabinet ministers and then selected from among
his people for nothing other than competence.
But he could virtue signal and then he set up the most important board,
let's say of the entire comp country on it.
Cause I random basis Jesus,
how pathetic.
He should have been pilloried by Canadians for that.
But we're so clued out and,
and also in this situation that you described,
just like if I say,
well,
50% of Trudeau's cabinet shouldn't have been women.
It's like,
oh,
you're a misogynist.
It's like,
no,
only 25% of the elected officials were women.
Now you might say,
well,
it would be better if 50% of the were elected.
It's like,
maybe it would be better,
but it didn't happen.
So you can't,
you can't fix it at the top end.
It was appalling.
So it's a hard argument to make,
you know,
because you need to know that there's more difference within groups then between
them in order to be able to come up with a credible argument,
you know?
And then so yeah.